two years ago this week we were the
first to lay out the detailed and
damning evidence that then niaid
director Dr Anthony fauci recklessly
broke Obama and Trump Administration
rules to commission Peter dassac's Eco
Health Alliance to carry out risky gain
of function experiments on back
coronaviruses with the Wuhan Institute
of virology in China experiments that
were the most likely cause of the
pandemic it was all dismissed by fauci
democrats and the media as a conspiracy
theory but this week for the first time
we started to get confirmation from
inside the US government that we were
right all along this report from the HHS
Inspector General investigated the exact
research project that we identified two
years ago news reports of this report
focused on generalized criticism of the
NIH Eco health and the Wuhan lab but it
seems to me no one's actually read the
report once you get over the dry
bureaucratic language there's a
bombshell here first of all we should be
clear that the central question whether
This research should have happened at
all is dodged as being a scientific
judgment that is beyond the scope of the
investigation well it very much needs to
be in the scope of the Congressional
investigation we'll get to that in a
moment but despite that look at this we
learned that in May 2016 the niaid
looked at the initial progress reports
from Eco health and determined that the
research could be gain a function that's
a quote that is news big news we now
know that people inside niaid were
worried that gained a function research
was being done in Wuhan as part of this
project you'd think they'd keep a close
eye on it but instead we now also know
that Eco Health Alliance should have
submitted a subsequent progress report
by the end of September 2019 but in fact
that progress report was handed in on
August the 3rd 2021 the Inspector
General says in the understatement of
the century this is particularly
concerning because NIH had already
raised concerns about gain a function
and when they finally got the progress
report it did indeed suggest that there
really had been gain of function carried
out so what happened between September
2019 when the progress report with
evidence of gain a function should have
been admitted and August 2021 when it
actually was oh just a global pandemic
that killed millions and upended the
entire world worse we read in this
report that if the procedures had been
followed it would have enabled quote new
biosafety measures to be enacted
to add insult to massive Global injury
Eco Health claimed that the reason that
their gain of function revealing
progress report was two years late was
they couldn't upload it to the NRH
website the inspector General's verdict
on that
quote we could not find evidence to
support that claim and here's the most
appalling part that should enrage every
single person on the planet the IG
report concludes with improved oversight
NIH may have been able to take more
timely corrective actions to mitigate
the inherent risks associated with this
type of research there you have it they
should never have commissioned This
research in the first place but even
once they did their incompetence and
carelessness meant they missed the
chance to prevent a global pandemic
there must be accountability for fauci
Francis Collins and everyone at the NIH
responsible for this massive and
completely avoidable catastrophe however
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now